THANKS, GENTLEMEN.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I WANT TO GIVE A LITTLE COVERAGE
HEARING IN THE HOUSE HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE THAT HAPPENED
YESTERDAY.
THE TAKE-AWAY FROM EXPERTS, MOST
OF THE LAWMAKERS THAT WERE
ASSEMBLED IS THAT THIS FIGHT
AGAINST DOMESTIC FORCES.
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS, EXTREMISTS
WOULD TAKE TEN TO 20 YEARS.
HOW DID THEY GET AT THAT NUMBER?
THEY COULDN’T SAY, WHICH BRINGS
ME TO THE SECOND SHOCKING THING.
THE FACT THAT VERY FEW
REPUBLICANS STOOD UP AND SPOKE
OUT AGAINST THIS INSANITY.
IN FACT, THE ONLY ONE WILLING TO
SAY PUMP THE BRAKES, WHOA, WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT WAS A
FRESHMAN CONGRESSMAN WHO HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE LESS THAN ONE
MONTH.
>> DO YOU AGREE THAT PEOPLE CAN
HAVE DIFFERING OPINIONS ON
DIFFERENCES AND IDEOLOGIES, BUT
THEY WON’T AFFECT THE JOBS THAT
THEY DO FOR OUR COUNTRY, BE IT
IN THE MILITARY, LAW ENFORCEMENT
OR POLITICAL OFFICE?
>> I FULLY APPRECIATE AND
PROTECT THE RIGHT THAT AMERICANS
HAVE DIFFERENT OPINIONS EVEN
THOUGH THAT I DON’T LIKE.
FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS NOT THE
FREEDOM TO COMMIT SADITION.
>> I TALKED ABOUT IDEOLOGIES.
>> Laura: VETTING PEOPLE FOR
IDEALOGICAL EXTREMISM.
THAT CONGRESSMAN, GEORGIA’S
ANDREW CLYDE JOINS ME NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, IT’S CLEAR THAT
DEMOCRATS ARE TROTTING OUT THESE
SO-CALLED EXPERTS TO CONFLATE
THE IDEA OF HAVING DIFFERING
OPINIONS WITH IF YOU’RE A
CONSERVATIVE AND YOU SUPPORTED
TRUMP, THEN YOU’RE GUILTY OF
SADITION.
YOU STILL HAVE YOUR INTEGRITY
AND YOU STOOD UP.
>> THANK YOU, LAURA.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
YES, THAT WITNESS WAS VERY
CONCERNING TO ME IN HIS
TESTIMONY.
I DON’T BELIEVE IN A POLITICAL
LITMUS TEST.
WE ALL RAISED OUR HAND TO THE
SAME OATH OF OFFICE, TO SUPPORT
AND DEFEND THE CONSTITUTION OF
THE UNITED STATES.
AS A NAVY OFFICER, 28-YEAR
VETERAN WITH COMBAT EXPERIENCE,
YOU KNOW, I DEFEND THAT FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT FOR EVERYONE.
>> Laura: IT’S REPORTED TONIGHT
THAT YOU AND CONGRESSMAN LOUIS
GOHMERT WERE FINED $5,000 FOR
BYPASSING HOUSE MEDAL DETECTORS.
A SECOND OFFENSE, BY THE WAY,
YOU HAVE TO SELL YOUR HOUSE.
IT’S A $10,000 FINE.
THAT WON YOU A NEW FAN, BY THE
WAY.
YOU DIDN’T KNOW THIS.
THIS WAS OVER AT CNN.
WATCH.
>> AND DREW CLYDE OF GEORGIA AND
LOUIS GOHMERT OF TEXAS.
TALK ABOUT ELITIST.
TOO GOOD FOR SAFETY?
SO MUCH FOR THE PARTY OF LAW AND
ORDER, RIGHT?
THIS IS WHY OTHER MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS ARE SCARED.
WHO WON’T GO THROUGH A SECURITY
CHECK?
WHAT DO YOU HAVE TO HIDE?
>> Laura: MR. BEEF CAKE OVER
THERE AT CNN IS TALKING ABOUT
MEN BEING SCARED?
BECAUSE YOU’RE WALKING AROUND --
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT.
>> YOU KNOW, THIS IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUE.
THOSE METAL DETECTORS ARE THERE
TO DETAIN US OR TO -- THAT’S A
VIOLATION OF ARTICLE 1, SECTION
6 OF THE CONSTITUTION.
WE’RE GOING TO THE HOUSE FLOOR
TO VOTE.
WE REPRESENT 700,000 PEOPLE IN
OUR DISTRICTS.
THE CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT WE
CANNOT BE IMPEDED WHEN WE GO TO
THE FLOOR TO VOTE.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN, ARE YOU
GOING TO PAY THE $5,000?
>> I’M GOING TO FIGHT IT.
I’M GOING TO APPEAL IT.
I’M GOING TO TAKE THEM TO COURT,
THIS IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
WE’RE ALL SET UP TO DO THAT.
I HAD TO HAVE STANDING, LAURA.
>> Laura: MAYBE YOU CAN ASK
NANCY IF YOU CAN BORROW HERE ICE
CREAM AND SELL IT.
YOU GOING TO DO IT AGAIN?
$10,000 NEXT TIME.
RUNNING UP THE TAB HERE.
ARE YOU GOING THROUGH THE METAL
DETECTOR NEXT TIME?
>> I’VE DONE IT A COUPLE TIMES.
THAT FINE WAS FOR A COUPLE DAYS
AGO.
I’VE HAD A COUPLE OF TIMES SINCE
THEN, I THINK.
SO I’M PROBABLY UP TO $25,000 BY
NOW.
>> Laura: MAYBE NEXT DETENTION,